[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: All right.
Well to my left, let's start
with our wonderful Ellen Hill
Zeringue from the Tigers.
Ellen?
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE:
Hi everybody.
And thank you for pronouncing
my name correctly.
Nobody ever does that.
It's like Zenger, Zengeroo.
It's every-- anyway.
So Ellen Hill Zeringue.
I'm Vice President of Marketing
for the Detroit Tigers.
I am entering into
my 20th season.
I started when I was very young.
And in my capacity as Vice
President of Marketing,
I oversee marketing, branding,
special events, promotions,
digital--
kind of everything that's fun.
I work very closely with
my colleague, Molly,
and also with my colleague
Marcia from Fox Sports Detroit.
I am a graduate of
Spelman College.
I have a degree in English.
And before I joined
the Detroit Tigers,
I worked in radio for Mix 92.3.
I was the Director
of Marketing there.
And before that, I
worked for a small agency
which is owned by an
African-American woman.
It was a special
events, promotions.
We did anything we
could do in the market
in the city of Detroit
to keep the doors open.
The name of the company was
Jackie-- was Vaughn Marketing
and was owned by Jackie Vaughn.
And I'm at the
Detroit Tigers today
because Jackie
Vaughn, after I left,
landed a contract at
the Detroit Tigers.
And this is all
about connections.
She landed a contract
at the Detroit Tigers
and called me when I was working
at the radio station and said,
I think that you should
become the Marketing
Manager for the Detroit Tigers.
So that's sort of my
story in a nutshell.
But again, it's
about connections.
My first boss out of
college got me the job
that I'm still in today.
[APPLAUSE]
MOLLY WURDACK-FOLT: Hello.
Good afternoon.
My name is Molly Wurdack.
And I'm the Director
of Marketing Strategy
with Olympia Entertainment.
So my primary responsibilities
here, actually
within Little Caesar's Arena
where we're sitting today,
are the oversight of all of
our partnership activation
that runs across all
of the properties
that we own, operate, and are
the facility managers for.
So that's here at Little
Caesar's Arena and the Detroit
Red Wings, over at Comerica
Park with the Detroit
Tigers, the Fox Theater.
All of those great venues
that we have the opportunity
to be able to partner with
on a day to day basis.
So those are my primary
responsibilities,
making sure that all
of our partnerships
are executed on a daily basis.
I started out my
career and the NFL.
I've been here with
Olympia Entertainment
for just over 11 years.
So made a really
big switch from--
I was talking to some women
earlier this afternoon
coming from Joe Lewis Arena to
here at Little Caesar's Arena.
It's been a big difference.
But all great staples
within the city of Detroit.
And so as I was mentioning
prior to my time here,
I was working in the NFL
with the Miami Dolphins.
So have been in sports
pretty much all of my career.
So it's been a fantastic ride.
I'm a graduate of
Ohio University.
Did my undergrad and my
two master's degrees there.
And my family and I
live in the suburbs.
And we have come to
know Detroit as home.
So being here 11 years,
although I'm not--
wasn't born and raised here,
this is where we call home now.
And we're so proud to
be a part of this city.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCIA TURNER: Hi.
I'm Marcia Turner.
And I'm Vice President
and General Sales Manager
for Fox Sports Detroit.
I have the privilege of working
with these ladies as well
as the Detroit Pistons.
We have the exclusive rights,
agreements for the Detroit
Tigers, Detroit Red Wings,
and the Detroit Pistons.
And so that allows me to work
with all of those brands.
My responsibility
at Fox Sports is
to sell advertising in all
of those different products,
not only on our
linear program or TV,
but also on our digital
platforms as well
and streaming.
We consider ourselves the
Cadillac, if you will,
of having these wonderful,
wonderful relationships
with our teams.
We are not anything if it's
not for Red Wings, Pistons,
and Tigers.
So we cherish the relationships
we have with them.
I personally call
these two friends.
If there's something
going on in my career,
these are two people
that I reach out
to talk to and vise versa.
So we've established very
long steadfast relationships.
I've been with Fox for 10 years.
I was with the Detroit
Free Press for 25 years,
basically doing the same thing.
Running the ad sales
department on the print side.
I too am a Detroiter.
I was born in New Jersey, but
moved here when I was seven.
So I consider myself
to be a raised--
born and raised person
from the city of Detroit.
We live in Detroit.
I have two daughters.
I graduated-- well I
graduated from Wayne State.
But went to Spelman
all four years.
So but came home and ended
up graduating the year
my dad died.
So but that's me.
That's it.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: I would like to say--
Molly, I actually
just recently met.
But to hear you all,
you know, again,
when you sit with people who are
great people and your friends
and you know them.
But then when you hear them
talk, you're like, really?
So I just had--
I just had a few really
moments, like, really?
Didn't know that.
Which is always a highlight.
So let's see.
Where do we begin?
It's Women's History Month.
So we will get down
to the nitty gritty.
Tell us what it is really
like being a woman in sports,
but a woman in sports
at an executive level.
Because oftentimes, we are
the only woman in the room
at the level that
you all sit at.
So as you all have had
these wonderful careers,
you know, position primarily
touching sports in some arena,
talk to us about how it has,
you know, where you started.
What you saw, but
where it is now
in terms of the
progression of how
women are participating at an
executive level with sports.
MARCIA TURNER: I'll
start with that.
I happen to work for
a General Manager who
has four women
running the top five
departments in the network.
So for Fox Sports
Detroit, there's
a woman in finance, a
woman running marketing,
a woman running
advertising, and a woman who
handles our traffic department.
So I'm in a really
unique situation,
if there is such a thing.
And I guess there's
not really unique.
But I'm in a unique
situation in the sense
that you don't hear of that
in most of the regional sports
networks.
But from the standpoint of
coming in at this level,
you know, you get a lot of men
who think, why in the world
would she be the person
that's responsible for all
of the sales?
And you all that are in this
room, you know, sales run--
it's pretty much the business
side of the organization.
But how can she--
she didn't play
professional sports.
Or she wasn't in
college in sports.
Or she didn't come
from one of the teams.
She came from newspapers.
The goal in obtaining me
for Fox Sports Detroit
was to grow our retail business.
And we have done that.
It's about dollar signs, right?
Can this person bring
in advertising revenue
and represent our product
in a way that elevates us?
And we doubled the revenue.
So I think we did just fine.
SPEAKER 1: Marcia's
actually being very modest.
Because she's also a GM--
General Manager.
And how many--
MARCIA TURNER:
General Sales Manager.
SPEAKER 1: General
Sales Managers.
How many in the United States?
It's only--
MARCIA TURNER: There's 12 of us.
And I'm the only female.
SPEAKER 1: She is the
only female General Sales
Manager in the United States.
And that is a big deal.
And of course, if
she's the only woman,
that means she's the only
African-American woman who
also holds that position.
So you know, again, in
a world right now that
is illuminated with so much
stress and diversity, you know,
good and bad, these type
of things, I believe,
are very important to
make sure that we note.
So oftentimes, when
I'm bragging about her,
that's exactly what I say.
Molly, go ahead.
MOLLY WURDACK-FOLT: Sure.
So when I started
out in the business,
unfortunately, I really
didn't have any female mentors
that I could look up to.
I was doing an interview
a couple of weeks
ago for a woman who writes a
blog specifically about women
in holding executive positions
in sports and entertainment.
Her question to me was,
well, so who's your mentor?
And while I've had
a number of mentors
throughout my career,
when I started,
there just weren't
a lot of women
who played in this space,
understood that there were
opportunities in this space.
And so, really for me,
it's really important
to make sure I'm continuing
to tell the story
and forge the path for younger
generations within the sports
and entertainment industry.
Because I didn't have that.
And while I had tremendous
mentors along the way,
and still do today, I never
had that female mentorship.
And so I think that
that's really important.
And as we rise to the
level at which we're
at from an executive
perspective,
that we remember
where we came from.
And we continue to give
back to the individuals who
are coming behind us.
Because we are going to forge
a path just as those before us
have done.
And we need to
make sure that it's
the right path for the women
that follow in our footsteps.
So I guess a little
bit different
take on your question.
But--
SPEAKER 1: This is a talk.
Anything--
MOLLY WURDACK-FOLT:
But for me, that's--
you know, there just wasn't
a lot of opportunities
when I started out.
And a lot of people to look up
to from a female perspective.
So that's sort of how I look
and approach business on a day
to day basis.
Everything that I do is about
giving back to the people
that I work with, that I
play in this community with,
and making sure that I'm
setting the right example,
no matter whether you're a
younger generation student,
whether you're a female,
whether you're a male.
I want to make sure that my
story is told not because I'm
necessarily a
female, but because I
do the right thing every day.
And I walk the walk,
I talk the talk.
And that's really what's
most important to me.
And I think great opportunities
for people coming behind us
to look towards.
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE:
What she said.
I agree.
When I first-- this is
going to sound kind of odd--
but when I first started
working in baseball,
I don't think I
really realized that I
was one of the only women.
Because the conversation
wasn't out there.
We weren't even thinking
about what are the spaces
and places where women are not?
And so that's become much
more prevalent recently.
I think for me,
when I first started
working in baseball what
was more significant
was that I was African-American.
But now, many, many
years later, it
is becoming
increasingly important--
and I'm reminded all the time
that I am one of the few women.
And I'm proud of that.
And I think that's one
of the responsibilities
that we have as women when we
are forging into new spaces
is that we have to realize
that we have something
to bring to the table, right?
And that we are
unique and different.
And that's OK and that's great.
And so think about
what it is about you
as a woman that you're bringing
to the table that is different
and that can change
the conversation.
So I frequently tell-- when
we're talking about marketing
in my office-- this
is a huge joke--
I frequently tell my team when
we're talking about something,
I say, OK, but what does
this single mom in Ferndale
with two kids think about that?
Can she afford to
come to the game?
Will her kids like doing that?
Because I believe very
strongly that as a woman,
I'm at the table for a reason
to keep the conversation going.
Same thing I feel about being
an African-American, right?
So I have a
responsibility of who
I am to keep the
conversation going
about things that haven't always
been discussed at the table.
I'm also like Molly,
super, super, super excited
about the incredible
number of women
that I know that we have
at Fox Sports Detroit.
But particularly at the
Red Wings and the Tigers.
We have so many young women.
And it is exciting to
see these young women.
And several of them are
back there in the room.
So many young women that
weren't there when I was there.
And I just believe
the future is so
exciting for what I know they're
going to bring to the table.
They're much more educated
than I was in terms of sports.
They all have these great sports
degrees and stuff like that.
I just came to the table cause
I could do marketing, right?
And it didn't exist.
So I'm thrilled about that.
And I also, like Molly,
and committed that I'm here
because I did have
two great mentors--
women mentors-- they
weren't in sports.
But they were amazing
women who mentored me
from a business perspective.
But I do everything
I can to make sure
that I'm reaching back
and helping to educate
and helping to have
those conversations.
If it's the, yes, you
need to take the yoga
pants off conversation, I'm
the one to do that, right?
Because I think the world is--
I think we're in a crisis.
We're in a yoga pants crisis.
So I'm the one
that will do that.
I'll also talk to you about--
right.
MARCIA TURNER: And flip-flops.
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE:
And flip-flops, right?
So it's important.
So I will have
those conversations
because somebody
did that for me.
And that's the only way we're
all going to survive as women
and continue to make great
contributions in sports.
MARCIA TURNER: I
just want to add,
since I didn't get to talk
about mentoring women.
It is so important.
And many of you in
the room who know me
know that I have mentees
and I pride myself
on making sure that we are
giving back in the same way
that Ellen and Molly
both spoke about.
It is imperative that women
when you get to this level,
that you find someone
that you can--
whose career you can touch,
that you can talk to.
That can call you at any time
and say, this is a dream.
This is something I want to do.
And you stop what
you're doing to make
that happen for that person.
I'm really, really big on that.
So I just wanted to add that.
See, you can't get
to the next question.
SPEAKER 1: No, this
is what we want.
This is a talk at Google.
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE:
And I just want
to add what Marcia said
about so there's mentoring.
But there's also
the friendships.
And Marcia said it earlier, that
she can call on me or Molly.
And you need that, right?
You need on your
executive level, whatever
level you're on, you
also need other women
that you can shut the door and
talk things through and say,
am I doing this right?
What do you think about this?
And share.
And so I'm thrilled that
I have these ladies.
There's also some other women--
Marcia's Director of Marketing
at Fox Sports Detroit, Lauren
Pober.
There's Rebecca Falk, who
is the Director of Marketing
over at Intercom Radio.
Those are like my soul sisters.
I talk to them like, a
gazillion times a day.
And it's really,
really important.
And I think that I
wouldn't be where
I am if it weren't
for the network
that I have in these women.
SPEAKER 1: That is wonderful.
Like I'm sitting
here getting excited.
So you guys said a few things
that definitely struck me
as we are sitting here.
So two things.
Let me see.
Which one do I
want to start with?
You all, actually,
besides it being
in the title, game changers.
Marcia, you specifically
mentioned that the technology
and the information that you all
began with even 10 years ago,
it did not exist.
You all have evolved
and watched social media
and all these other platforms--
Google.
We're not that old--
impact your business.
Tell us what that looks
like from where you sit.
We see it from, oh, I can
watch sports anywhere now.
But talk to us
about the evolution,
the technology, you know,
of what sports is now.
Because not only were
you game changers,
but you are actually at the
position now of dictating
and saying the type
of technology that
needs to evolve to support
what people are looking for,
what they're requiring.
So what does that
look like for you all?
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE:
Go ahead Marcia.
I saw you.
I was like, yes.
MARCIA TURNER: It is true.
You can watch TV
anywhere, right?
We watch it on our phones,
we watch it on our tablets,
we watch it on our
70 inch screens.
And the beauty of
a technology now,
you don't have to sit somewhere
stationary to see a game.
And one of the strengths
that Fox Sports
has is the fact that we
are on everything, right?
We're on Roku, we're
on your cable box,
we're on your Sling TV.
We're everywhere.
You can access sports.
Now you may have to
authenticate, right?
Through a cable
subscriber or something.
But you're always going to be
able to watch their games--
the Red Wings or the
Tigers or the Pistons--
on Fox Sports Detroit.
So technology, from
our perspective,
has just allowed us to open
the world to our games.
Let everyone be able to see
the games wherever they are.
Is that kind of what you're--
SPEAKER 1: What's
the challenges, too?
The same thing.
Because it's
happening, you know.
But as you sit
here, what are some
of the new technologies
or just things
that you all are
seeing evolving?
MARCIA TURNER: People that--
so I'm in sales, right?
And what is traditional
sales is to sell TV, right?
I want to see those
commercials on television.
And it can be a
struggle for some
because they feel that we're
competing with ourselves when
we sell streaming.
It's-- OK, that's a lesser rate.
It's maybe not as conducive as
TV would be to a major agency.
You're certainly not
going to get the dollars
from that standpoint.
But the reality is, people
want to see it where they are.
They want to watch
TV where they are.
And we have to be able
to grow with the fact
that you're going to get
less money for that schedule.
But it's beneficial to our
company and our overall way
in which we're doing
business to recognize
that we need to sell digitally
and we need to sell streaming
and we need to build
those packages,
just as what we started
with regular TV.
So.
MOLLY WURDACK-FOLT: So from
the sponsorship perspective,
it's certainly changed in
the last even five years,
but even 10 years.
And where we were 10 years
ago was really the basic--
the sale of what we would call
in the industry spots and dots,
right?
And that's what it was about.
And that's certainly
still a component
of selling partnerships and
activating partnerships now.
But what's becoming
more and more prevalent
is the desire for
brands to be integrated
into the brand in which
they're partnering with
to have a connection.
And that is driven so much
through social, digital, web,
all of those kinds of things.
And so we need to
continuously be
creative in thinking
about new assets
that we can help bring to
these partnerships that
live above and beyond a sign
on a wall or a nice logo.
While all those things are
great and very important.
They provide extreme value
and exposure to partners.
It's about that
extended and next level
connection to the
customer that these brands
want to partner with.
So our ability to have
engagement with athletes
and how does that come to life
through social opportunities?
Are opportunities
to be able to--
if you have been downstairs
in the concourse at Little
Caesar's Arena-- to look
at augmented reality,
virtual reality.
How these kinds of things come
to life within your building,
within your brand,
are really important.
And I think augmented reality,
virtual reality, specifically,
are two really big areas.
While not totally
new technology,
they're definitely
pieces of technology
that can be taken
to the next level,
especially from a team
and a building perspective
that we're going to continue to
look to see how we can leverage
moving forward.
I'd say the challenge is
while similar to Marcia,
is certainly the adoption
of the new products.
It also requires a pretty
significant investment
up front sometimes.
And so to be able
to create the story
and be able to communicate
what the RLY is
to your leadership about
how this is going to deliver
on the back end, not
only financially, which
is most of the time the number
one and most important thing.
But also how it's
going to create that
extended connection
to the customer.
We talked-- Ellen and I
were actually at a meeting
this morning.
And we were talking
about experiences.
And it's not just about
coming to a game anymore.
It's about the
experience that you
have with your spouse, with
your son or your daughter,
with your neighbor.
And so all of those
pieces of technology
can help bring that experience
to life more and enhance it.
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE:
And I would also,
to sort of add on to what Molly
is saying, it's also about--
so I don't know how many people
have used the District app.
Not the ones who work
for the district.
OK.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
That's a shout out, Ellen.
Tell everyone where
we should download
and what we should
be experiencing.
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE:
The District App.
Particularly because
you're in this building.
So the District App is
amazing because it really
helps to change the way that
you navigate and experience
the arena.
It's like your personal little
guide is right there with you
and it gives you
parking information,
it talks about merchandise.
And also if you download
the app, you can get--
correct me if I'm wrong, Amanda,
and Molly-- you can get--
there might be different
discount offers
that you might get at
times, programmed into it.
My point is this.
That the way-- the
customer expectation
in terms of how they
navigate arenas and ballparks
has changed dramatically.
And so that's what
Molly's talking about.
She's talked about it from
a sponsorship standpoint.
But I mean from just from a
customer service experience.
There's lots of things that we
used to do or lots of things
that we-- just the
way we interact
with, the places that we
go has completely changed.
The other thing I want to say
is that, it's all about content.
That's the biggest thing that
has changed from a marketing
standpoint.
The social media group falls
under my responsibility
at the ballpark.
And we just hired
a content producer.
And all he's-- down
in spring training.
And all he's doing is
creating these videos.
Videos, videos, videos.
Because we have to grow
our social platform.
And that is totally
different than what
it was like when I first--
when I first started working
at the Tigers, we used to
take the newspaper clips
and copy them on the copy
machine and pass them around.
And that's how we knew what
was going on in the world.
OK hello.
I've been there a long time.
But think about it now.
We, as a brand, have to
come up with content.
And the other thing is
that a couple of years
ago, you know, the ninth inning,
turn the lights off, go home.
That's it.
We'd report back at
9:00 AM in the morning.
No.
It is 24 hours,
seven days a week.
And we have to be
able to drive content,
add content, and then also
monitor player content.
Monitor what customers
and consumers
are saying about our
brand and how we interact.
So I would just say
that we have become just
a 24 hour, seven
day a week business
because of the
impact of digital.
MARCIA TURNER: I just want to
add something about content.
As Ellen was talking about
our social media platforms,
those have grown
just exponentially.
And we have a social
media manager who is 24/7.
Courtney is posting and engaging
with fans about the three
brands that we represent.
But it's a constant process.
And in addition, we have all
had to become much more familiar
with social media platforms.
I mean, I used to use
Instagram to just monitor
my daughter's Instagram.
Now I'm like a real player
on Instagram, you know?
I'm following people.
I'm watching things
that are going on.
But it also is
important to watch
what's going on in our industry
through Instagram and Twitter.
And I've got followers.
And it's just mind boggling
that I'm in this space
today when I too copied
everything off the newspaper,
cut it out, sent it
to all my clients,
would run over to the Detroit
Tigers and tell Ellen,
did you read this?
You're marketing.
You really should be buying
this in the newspaper.
And that's how our world was.
But it's no longer that today.
And so Fox Sports continues
to evolve, if you will,
with our social platforms as
well as our digital platforms.
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE: Can I
just add one quick thing?
And the other thing
is the one thing
that we're still competing with
is the live game experience.
So there's all
these wonderful ways
for people to watch the game.
The game can go with you.
You can do all-- you
can pause the game.
But I still want you to
come to the ballpark.
I need you to come
to the ballpark
and I need you to
enjoy the green grass
and have a conversation with
your friend and have a beer,
have a hot dog, have a
Miller Coors product.
I need you-- have a Pepsi.
Have a Pepsi.
Little Caesar's Pizza.
But that's important, right?
That is really our
biggest competitor
from a marketing
standpoint is that people
can take it with you.
And that's great.
But I also need you--
and I think Fox Sports
Detroit is great about this.
They understand that
there's an intricate balance
between promoting the digital
interaction with the product
and also with driving people.
Because they don't want an
empty ballpark more than I do.
MARCIA TURNER: It doesn't
show up well on TV.
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE: It
doesn't show up well on TV.
It's not fun, right?
So together, we are
figuring out how
to create this
method or this model
so that we're driving
people into the ballpark
to experience it live.
But also asking them to enjoy
it on their mobile devices
that we can integrate different
messages that we need to so
that Marcia can deliver, and my
group-- our sponsorship group,
Molly-- can get what they
need from a sales standpoint.
SPEAKER 1: How do you
all juggle it all?
And I'm asking specifically
as I'm hearing this,
working in a marketing
world, knowing, you know,
the challenges.
Being a mother, having
friends, families,
all of these things
which is innate to women.
We somehow figure out
how to juggle it all.
But at the same time, as you
are existing in this world
to do all things as a woman,
how are you all doing that?
Because to go from using the
copier and running over--
I think that is so--
I cannot wait to turn
this into a snippet.
Oh these are going to be short.
So I was like, oh this is
social media gold right now.
That's what I'm
actually thinking.
MARCIA TURNER: I was not lying.
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE:
Marcia was--
I was Marcia's client.
And that's how we met.
I was Marcia's client at the
Detroit News and Free Press.
And she is not kidding.
She would drive the newspaper
over to me and go, here Ellen.
Did you see this?
You should-- this is how we're
going to lay your ad out.
That was so embarrassing.
MARCIA TURNER: Forget
that Google stuff.
It was like, get in your
car and Google over there.
SPEAKER 1: Well now seriously,
words of wisdom, you know?
We hear it, and
you make it happen.
And it seems seamless.
And I think, especially sitting
on the side of supporting
entrepreneurs--
many in this room--
you know, you struggle
with feeling adequate,
which oftentimes, being a woman
and all these other things
of lives changing and
how do we stay relevant?
And all these things that
are socially, I feel like,
put on us anyway.
You know, you're looking at.
But really, what are
your words of wisdom
at being a such a high level?
Being the only in your position
oftentimes, if not in the room
at a very minimum, how do
you actually, you know--
how do you just keep
some type of balance?
What would you recommend
or what would you say?
And it may not be real balance.
But you know, day by day,
how do you handle it?
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE:
I have to go first?
I can't, like, feed
off of their ideas?
So this is going to sound
really, really crazy.
But one of the things that I
am committed to doing is making
sure-- this is going
to sound crazy--
that I feel good
about the way I look.
So I tell the young
women in my office
who do special
events and promotions
and they're working long
hours and stuff that.
I'm like, nope.
Stop.
While you're planning an
event, I'm like, nope, stop.
The event going to
start in a minute.
Go put your makeup on, comb
your hair, look organized.
Because if you
don't look organized
and you don't feel
organized, then no one
else is going to have
confidence in you.
So you know, I try to have
everything in my office
from like, makeup, toothbrush,
extra shoes, everything
so that I can always
come presentable.
Because that actually
makes a difference.
And you actually will
feel good about yourself.
So it's about being prepared
and having all those resources.
And then a friend
that you can go,
do I have something in my teeth?
And she'll tell you the truth.
So that's part of it.
And then also, I think
you have to have a hobby.
Right?
Because we work really,
really, really long hours.
I'm not sure how Marcia does
it because she has to champion
Red Wings, Tigers, and Pistons.
So at least I get a little
bit of an off season.
But you have to have a hobby.
I have become an avid reader.
I read all of the
time because it's
the only time when I'm at home
that I can just sort of escape.
And you have to give
yourself the escape.
Because you have to
have that balance.
And for a long time I didn't
give myself that balance.
And I worked-- we were
81 home games, right?
So that's a lot.
And then sometimes
they start at 7 o'clock
and during the evenings, and
sometimes they'll end at 9:00,
sometimes they'll end at 10:00.
Sometimes they'll
have a rain delay
and they'll end much
later than that.
So you have to force yourself to
have a hobby and give balance.
MOLLY WURDACK-FOLT: I think
Katrina's word, juggle,
is probably-- at least
in my experience--
better than balance.
I don't truly know
if there is a balance
to be had in sports
and entertainment.
I mean, there's not a
job description out there
that doesn't say nights,
weekends, holidays.
Should they be
prepared to dig in.
Because it's a lot.
But certainly in addition
to what Ellen said,
I would say it's
really important
to have a support system.
Whatever that means for you.
For me, it's my husband.
We work both crazy hours.
But he supports me and
supports my career.
And so we make
sacrifices every day
to make sure that each one
of us has the opportunity
to grow and succeed
in what we want to do.
But that may be different
for the person sitting
across the table from you.
It may be your parents.
It may be your daughter.
It may be the people
that you work with.
I can tell you that I would
not make it through the day
if it were not for the
people that work here.
For the women that sit in
the back of this room who
I work with every day,
they keep me going.
And that support
system is so important.
If you don't have
that support system
inside of work and outside of
work, it's going to be tough.
It's going to be hard.
What keeps you
going if you don't
have those people around
you every single day
that you want to
go to battle for?
It makes the nights,
the weekends,
all the long hours worth it
when you have the support
system that's there to help
keeping you going when,
it's not all roses, right?
There are tough times.
And so you need those people to
be able to help keep you going.
MARCIA TURNER: Everything
that they said.
But the juggling part, I
didn't think about it that way.
But Molly, you're
absolutely correct.
It's hard to say
what balance is.
And what balance is to one
person is probably not balance.
In my life, I do a
lot of games, right?
I go to Reds Wings,
Pistons, and Tigers games,
as Ellen mentioned.
And then I, you know, I've
got two daughters, you know?
They're 27 and 20.
And both out of town now.
So I'm really that empty nester.
But I adopted a dog, so I'm
really not an empty nester.
Cause she is super important.
But, and so life balance
even includes the dog, right?
My mother comes to my house
every day from 11:00 to 3:00
just to kind of
see after the dog.
She misses her grandkids.
But she thinks the dog is good.
She thinks the dog's cool.
But I also want to add
that having good friends,
people in the business,
people out of the business.
I'm in a lot of
ladies organizations.
I get a lot of strength and
encouragement from that.
I have a lot of professional
things that I do.
There is a lot of strength and
balance that comes with that.
And then I'm a golfer, you know?
And so I've picked up golf.
Maybe 20, 25 years ago.
And I, on Wednesday nights,
I play with my league
and I'm there every Wednesday.
And I move things
around so that I
can make sure that I
do the one hobby that I
enjoy that I do that.
And so I think you have to find
things that you enjoy and make
that a part of your life.
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE: I was
just going to say, and also
create a schedule.
So I get my hair done at 6:30
in the morning on Fridays.
So that she just went at 6:30
in the morning on Thursday.
But that's so that I don't
have to-- hair is important.
Hair is important to me.
But I don't have to deal with
that in the middle of the week,
in the middle of the day, right?
Marcia goes to yoga at
5:00 AM in the morning.
I'm supposed to,
but I never make it.
But Marcia goes to yoga
at 5:00 AM in the morning
two days a week so that she
can get that out of the way
so that she can then
start her day fresh.
And the maintenance
things are out of the way.
So it's kind of
important to think
about your schedule
and the things that
are important to you.
And how can you create a day so
that you can get all the things
in it that you need
to do and still
feel really good about yourself
and think about expanding,
you know, 6:00 AM is
really not that early.
It's not that early
to get my hair done.
It's kind of early for yoga.
But anyway.
MARCIA TURNER:
Get to yoga Ellen.
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE: She's going
to call me tomorrow morning.
Get to yoga.
MARCIA TURNER: Get to yoga.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
So I'm going to switch it up
a little bit before we open up
the floor for
answer and question.
Because Ellen actually
has a hard stop.
I just feel so
privileged right now
that you all were able to
come together-- and be clear.
Part of them being
able to come together
was related to opening day.
Everybody, I was like, so
how is opening day affecting
everybody's schedule.
No, not that week.
Not that day.
Spring training.
I was like, this is real.
You know, when you--
in their lives, you
know, we look at sports
and it's so glamorous and
glorious as you see it.
But when you get to the
business side of it--
and I can say from
personal experience--
sometimes, I'm like, you
have another game today?
As much as I like
sports, I'm like, you do?
You are where today?
But you know, definitely
a highlight and a benefit.
So we'll do a little bit,
just quick round robin,
just to hear, you
know, a little--
and whatever comes
first to your mind.
So as I'm looking at
you Ellen, [INAUDIBLE]..
Who are you?
Like, one word, who Ellen is.
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE: A friend.
MOLLY WURDACK-FOLT: Strong.
SPEAKER 1: You guys
[INAUDIBLE] mic.
MARCIA TURNER: Compassion.
I'm a compassionate person.
SPEAKER 1: When you are
making those hard decisions
and having those tough
conversations, who
are you then?
MARCIA TURNER: You know, I--
this--
MOLLY WURDACK-FOLT: One word!
MARCIA TURNER: It requires
more than one word.
That requires more
than one word.
And it's interesting that
you gave the mic to me
and I said compassion.
When I am having a rough
time, or, you know,
you have employees that
are having a rough time,
or you have issues
that are going on,
I'm still
compassionate, you know?
And one of the podcasts--
I listen to a lot of podcasts.
If you guys don't
do that, you really
should listen to podcasts.
They're really great.
But I was listening to a
podcast with Jeff Weiner,
who is CEO for LinkedIn.
And he talks about
compassionate leadership.
And as I'm listening to this
guy, I'm like, that's me.
I have literally fired a person
and went and had wine with them
that same evening.
It doesn't take-- you
don't have to be mean.
If someone is not
doing their job,
then you need to-- it's on you.
You need to either figure
out how to train that person
to do their job, or how to
find a role that perhaps they
would be better suited for, or
find a way to transition them
out of that role, right?
I mean, it's not--
it is personal, but it's
not personal, right?
It's about whether or not this
business is right for you.
And I think you can do all
of that with compassion.
SPEAKER 1: Before
you answer, Molly,
that is such a good point,
because Women's History Month,
women's panel.
Men, traditionally, do
not have to explain that.
When we talk about
hard conversations,
we talk about, you
know, butting heads,
working for opposite
teams, all of those things.
When it comes to
men, generally, it's
almost celebrated,
like, hey, you know,
they had a hard conversation.
I had to tell him how it is.
But we went out to
dinner afterwards.
However, when a woman
who is the executive,
the president, or the CEO,
now it becomes a conversation.
Because it was, oh she fired me.
And now it becomes
something else,
like, almost how dare you?
And many of us,
even if you haven't
experienced it
personally, I know
you probably heard the story.
So just to, you know, that
really resonated well with me.
Because I think about my career.
And I was fired one
time when I was younger.
And he told me,
Kay, you gotta go.
And I just looked at
him, like [INAUDIBLE]..
But to this day, Mr.
Johnson-- hi Mr. Johnson!
Still love him to this day.
It was the best thing because
I was going through my--
I was actually just coming out
of high school and all that.
But he fired me.
And it was OK.
And he made me stronger.
And I ended up working together
with him again as I go--
I still go see him and all
of those type of things.
But being a woman,
you know, that's
just one of the things
that just touched me,
that we typically
don't have to explain.
But you're right.
The description of
it, when he fired me,
and I experienced that,
he was naturally still--
it was almost like--
I knew it was with love.
I knew I needed to step it up.
He was frustrated and he
did what he had to do.
And it was one of my best
life learned lessons.
MARCIA TURNER:
Normally they are.
Normally they are
when you have to make
that kind of a decision.
But I won't--
MOLLY WURDACK-FOLT: Thorough.
SPEAKER 1: Molly's like--
MOLLY WURDACK-FOLT:
And she said one word.
No, rule follower.
SPEAKER 1: No, no, no.
MARCIA TURNER: And
you know I'm not.
So.
SPEAKER 1: Thorough.
And what would you add to that?
Because I really liked how
Marcia elaborated on it.
You're thorough.
But words of wisdom?
Hard conversations.
MOLLY WURDACK-FOLT: Yeah.
I mean, for me, when we're
making difficult decisions
and having conversations
at an executive level,
it's important to
be-- it doesn't really
matter what level you're at.
When you're making
a decision, it
is important to be thorough
and thoughtful about everything
that could possibly be
affected by the decision
that you're doing, right?
In your personal life,
in business, right?
Every decision that you
make has consequences,
has repercussions.
Whatever it might be.
Has positive outcomes.
So being thorough and
thinking through all
of the possibilities
is really important.
It's very easy to be able
to be first to judge,
to be first to talk, right?
But how do we take a step
back and listen, absorb,
think about everything that
may be a result of the decision
that we're making.
And then make the decision.
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE:
So you're going--
you're thinking-- you're
going to think I was cheating.
I wasn't.
I was going to
say knowledgeable.
And that is similar
exactly to what
Molly was saying to make
sure that I have asked
the second, third,
and fourth question
before I make a decision.
And to make sure that everything
has been thought through
and exactly what Molly said.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
I cannot believe
we're at 1:52 so fast.
So I am actually going to
open the floor for questions.
And I think this
is a perfect time.
We've definitely touched
upon a few topics.
I did not say this
at the beginning.
The hashtag, of course,
is #GoogleDigitalCoaches.
I'm totally giving
myself a plug.
And hashtag #TalksAtGoogle,
to be honest with you.
So use those two hashtags
if you catch pictures today.
I hope you are.
So all right.
I am going to go ahead and
come out of picture view
and we'll focus on them.
But Tony, have a question?
AUDIENCE: So there
are some statistics
around the fastest group of
entrepreneurs in the country.
And happen to be
women of Michigan.
And so my question is, how
engaged are your organizations
or yourself personally
with the startup
community of female
entrepreneurs here in Detroit,
if at all?
MARCIA TURNER: I just
went to the Lip Bar.
If you haven't been to the Lip
Bar, guys, that is so cool.
I am like, oh my god.
This-- but I'm telling you.
Detroit is just a cool
spot right now, right?
And there are so
many different places
that you can go in
the downtown area
and in [INAUDIBLE],,
in neighborhoods
that are owned by women.
So if I read about
a place, I try
to make it my business to
frequent the Woodburns Spa.
Wood Spa.
Another woman owns that.
There are tons of places.
And I try to look for them.
I try to search out,
you know, making sure
that I'm not giving back to the
community in which I live in.
I volunteer a lot.
So I got that covered.
AUDIENCE: And even if
you see opportunities
within your organizations
to engage with start-ups,
if you identify possibilities.
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE: So
Major League Baseball
has a Diverse Business
Partners Program.
And it's specifically
designed to make sure
that we are engaging with women
and minority owned businesses.
So I would encourage
you to go look
at Major League Baseball and
the Diverse Business Partners
Program.
And also that program
is extended, obviously,
through the Detroit
Tigers, right?
That's not my area of expertise.
So I don't want to
really elaborate.
But there is a commitment that
we do business with small--
with women owned and
minority owned businesses.
The other thing is
that I think that I
would take a look at
the District Detroit
and I would look at the space
that we're in and this area.
There's lots of opportunities
for development here.
So if you're looking
for an-- and I, again,
that's not my area of expertise.
But I do know that the idea
is that we're obviously
going to continue to grow
the District Detroit.
But this is a perfect place.
I mean, if you are a small
business owner or a business
owner, and you want to try
to be at the right place
where you have 40,000 fans from
Comerica Park and 60,000 fans
from Ford Field and
20,000 fans at LCA,
this is the place to be.
So I would do your due diligence
if you're a small business
owner.
Large business owner,
and try to figure out
how you can do something
with the District Detroit.
At least investigate.
MOLLY WURDACK-FOLT: You
know, similar to Marcia,
I definitely try to frequent
a lot of those businesses here
downtown.
Specifically one that I
frequent very often is K9 to 5.
Love them.
Woman entrepreneur
and business owner.
So my dogs are so appreciative
because they do not
love the inside of my walls
of my house every single day.
But beyond that, I
would say, in addition
to what the Tigers are doing--
specifically the Tigers,
and then certainly
on a league level, us
here at the Red Wings
are continuously looking
at ways that we impact
the community in which we live.
And moving here to
the District Detroit
has opened up a lot of
opportunities for us.
And so, on our website,
there is a whole showcase
of areas in which we are
touching the community that we
work in.
And always looking to
expand on that work.
So again, similar to Ellen.
This is not my
area of expertise.
But I did oversee
community relations
for a couple of years.
And the individual who runs
that is a fantastic gentleman,
Kevin Brown.
Him and his team do a lot and
he is extremely passionate
about this city and
the work that us
as an organization, the
Detroit Red Wings, Olympia
Entertainment, can do to impact
the community that we work in.
AUDIENCE: My name
is [INAUDIBLE]..
When I can go back--
I can speak loud.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I actually work in PR,
communications, marketing,
all of that whole
umbrella thing.
But my passion has
always been more focused
on the entertainment,
sports, music side of things.
Now granted, it's very
difficult, obviously,
to get into those types of
fields, especially as a woman--
young woman, woman of
color, just different types
of those aspects.
So you guys have gave me
some great gems to take home.
But if you could
kind of let me know
what kind of spaces people
or organizations or things
I should look into to
try to find those types
of opportunities to work in it?
MARCIA TURNER: Are
you still in college?
AUDIENCE: No.
MARCIA TURNER: OK.
So you're--
AUDIENCE: I'm a
professional now.
I'm a senior account executive
up the street at a PR firm.
But just kind of looking
for, you know, advice.
MARCIA TURNER: I
mean, I would tell you
like I tell my 28-year-old.
If you're waiting for someone to
come and find you, they won't.
So go find what it is
that you're looking for.
If it's I want to work in
TV, find someone on TV,
write them a note,
send them an email.
I answer all of my emails.
I may not answer them soon,
as these ladies may say.
She'll get to you.
But I answer all of them.
And as we all have
expressed, we are
really passionate about trying
to formulate relationships
with women, younger women, women
who aspire to do what we do.
So find it.
Look for it.
Send the person a note.
Send them a text message.
Send them an email.
Get on their Instagram.
You can Google, right,
through LinkedIn.
You know, Google them, find
out what they're doing.
And hit them up on LinkedIn.
I mean, I answer all of it.
So, and try to get
some direction there.
MOLLY WURDACK-FOLT: I would
also say to use your network.
This town is-- while we are
very large, we are very small.
And I guarantee
that you probably
know a handful of people
that know people that
work across sports and
entertainment industry
just here in Detroit.
And so use your network.
Talk to people.
I mean, just buy people
coffee, take them out to lunch.
Just pick their
brain, get to know,
see who they know,
who they don't know,
how they can make
introductions for you.
And I guess my piece of advice--
this is not a room of students.
But use-- don't
go to your network
when you need something.
And so different, I
understand, because you're
interested in this space.
But always keep that in mind.
That's something that's
really important to me
is making sure that I'm
exercising my network
all year round, even
when I don't necessarily
need something.
Because there's nothing
worse than somebody
that comes to you just when
they need something, right?
So.
MARCIA TURNER: That's the
only time you hear from them.
ELLEN HILL ZERINGUE: I
would just add real quickly.
Think out of the box, right?
So there's 30 major
league baseball teams.
So there's only 30 of me.
So you have to think about
what are the other companies,
programs, products that touch
sports or touch entertainment.
I always tell interns that.
They say I want
to work in sports.
I'm like, OK, well
that doesn't mean
you have to work for a
team, or for a league.
It means you could
work in broadcasting,
or you could work for a
very high level partner
corporation that invests a lot
in their sports sponsorships.
So there's all
different kinds of way
of looking at sports
and entertainment,
not just the traditional ways.
And it might be a
little bit easier
to get into one of the
non-traditional ways
than one of the
traditional ways.
But I wish you great success.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
SPEAKER 1: Can you
say phenomenal?
[APPLAUSE]
Phenomenal women.
Phenomenal.
Phenomenal for so many reasons.
And I want to say thank you all.
Thank you so much.
As a lady, I'm getting a little
sappy here, a little teary.
So we're going to pull it in.
But again, I have the
opportunity to speak often.
Always impressed with
the people that I meet.
And you know, always
love to hear stories,
always love to ask questions.
So being able to ask questions
and hear the stories of people
that you look up to,
people that you love,
people that you can call on
and they will be there for you
at a drop of a dime.
So now Molly, I feel like, oh.
Welcome to the party, sister.
And it feels good because
we're in a space right now.
And I'm entering that space too.
It's a little bit weird for me.
But I'm there too, where
when people call me,
it makes me feel great
that I can answer.
Trina, I need-- yes, what is it?
Give me 15 minutes and I
will call you right back.
And generally, I'm a
pretty good connector.
And it's because of, you know,
the leadership, the mentorship,
and the things that have
happened in my life for women
like this who sit here, who
have made it happen for me.
I've always told people, I
give because those gave to me
when I was not deserving.
Even when I did not deserve
the opportunity, so I felt,
they saw something in
me and said, it's OK.
It's OK.
I believe you and I
know you will be OK.
Even if you're not all
the way there right now,
I will stand there for you
and I will support you.
And this panel today
is a testimony to that.
Because I know I was
totally, like, Lord,
please allow them all to
have a scheduled time that
will meet up.
And that will work for
them and everybody.
And even Google and everyone
who's sitting in this room.
Because I had a mild panic
attack before I started.
I was like, oh god.
Who's coming?
I was like, they are somebody.
But is somebody coming to see?
So I just want to say thank you.
Thank you so much.
We're going to actually
wrap up, again,
because their time
is very valuable,
we don't want to
overextend them.
You may be able to catch them.
We have to do a
couple of things,
which be the formal of
take a couple of pictures
and, you know, shake
a couple of hands.
So if they can't get
to you right now,
don't be discouraged.
They are accessible
as we had mentioned.
So I think that's about it.
So thank you so much
for joining us today.
Talks at Google.
Game Changers in Sports.
We had our wonderful panelists,
Marcia Turner, Molly--
let me get it right this time--
MOLLY WURDACK-FOLT: Wurdack.
SPEAKER 1: Marcia Turner, Molly
Wurdack, Ellen Hill Zeringue.
Thank you so much for joining
us for official Talks at Google,
sponsored by Google
Digital Coaches, Detroit.